in five four three two one welcome
everybody to another episode of the
genius brain podcast I'm your host David
so and we got that reoccurring guest
Christine oh so sad
order what up what up so you got a
podcast too now I do have a podcast but
they're trying to creep on my [ __ ] was
it called keeping it true I'll see of
course of course
h-town you know it sound native so he's
keeping it trill I have another co-host
of my cousin bhakti Durant and yeah and
we actually we bet we've only had like a
few guests we're still like in the
process of like figuring things out yeah
I mean we're like weird like 38 episodes
in but 38 episodes in you never plug
that [ __ ] when you're here before I
don't know that's what that's what I'm
talking about how I'm still new to this
[ __ ] yeah I'm still new to like plugging
my podcast or or bringing guests on yeah
and like trying to collab and stuff so
yeah I don't know we like in the podcast
space is weird because one of the things
that I didn't want to predicate this
podcast on was having crazy big guests
and I think people want to see those
guests because I just wanted the podcast
to be about regular conversation yeah
yeah and the reason why is because I
feel like and I know where I'm at in my
career I don't want anybody that
important here so I thought I mean you
call me by my government that that's
what's telling me how I'm not as real I
like call you Christina because it
reminds me of a cookie
put some [ __ ] cheese on that
Christina I've never heard that before
that's what it sounds like to me a
cookie yeah let me get a little
Christina right there man just break me
off a piece
macadamia yeah but yeah when we when we
started this podcast and when I started
this podcast just because I felt that
the success of a podcast was highly best
based on the guests and not the stories
and sometimes when these celebrities
come on they don't really have much to
say aside from the fact that I think
their clout kind of drives traffic to
something but I just didn't want it to
be highly based on that and I feel like
a lot of people have great stories like
I have a guest coming on too
Morrow she's not really anybody famous
at all but her story is very unique and
I wanted to share her story because she
hit me up through a message and she was
talking about wanting to kill herself
okay I was like oh [ __ ] well first of
all the reason why that freaked me out
is because I've never wanted to kill
myself I've never I've never had those
thoughts in my head yeah I don't know
what that feels like yeah and I mean
what do you say it's like this one time
when my this is kind of funny but my my
buddy his father passed away right you
can't say this is kind of funny and then
follow up with well welcome to the black
ass [ __ ] alright anyways his father
killed himself now I'm kidding that's
not like but his his dad his pops now
this guy is just a very dramatic human
being okay and this is what I'm used to
him being dramatic guys you know I kind
of grew up around dudes when they when
they went through stuff yeah they would
reach out but they would kind of collect
themselves first and then reach out so
they can really articulate how they feel
or what they're saying they wouldn't
just start blubbering in front of you
because you know who really knows how to
deal with that situation right I'm not
very good with those situations yeah so
you know I guess when it happened he
hits me up and then he's like yeah I
just want to kick it and be around
friends I'm like cool let's kick it and
there's two people with me and my other
buddy now my other buddy he's a lot more
sensitive than I am it's very sweet he
comes up to him he gives him that bro
hug hugs it out I think he gave butt
kiss autos for it which I thought was
really weird oh you know it's like yeah
man just you know we good bro you came a
kiss on his forehead just like yo man
keep your head up yeah and then we're
just talking kiss the kiss on your on
your boy on your homie that's that's a
that's a different level of love see
there's two ways that could have gone
right yeah that could have been on some
like that's some really awkward [ __ ] and
but I think if your thug enough that's
like one of them like you know Birdman
and Lil Wayne say like it has to be like
the the placement of the kids like is it
gonna be like like kind of on the cheek
you know I mean where you just press a
cheese like I love you boy you know it's
on the lips like awesome
like you said Birdman Lil Wayne it was
it on the lips they were on the lips bro
they went and he went to go accept award
and went up on stage and at the pedestal
they kiss they get look what the [ __ ]
yeah bro I never saw the video so I just
assumed that it was you know on the
cheek or something I was like that's a
little suss but at the same time if
that's how they roll and that were
saying like that's my son
you know that's my son that's what
else's thing yeah even if fish's son
your son's kind of old cut that [ __ ] out
eventually yeah yeah yeah but some
people will be like yo that's like that
[ __ ] toxic male masculinity [ __ ] yeah
man yeah [ __ ] kids mommy yeah it was
like [ __ ] on the cheek you know say I
don't forgot you boy like yeah yeah I
don't yeah this is so in love you know
it's one of those things I found out his
girl was pregnant oh yeah it was he was
17 and we were like bro it's like I felt
it with him like what would life just go
yeah bro yeah so it was like it was a
crazy situation where I just had I was I
was like there for him and you know we
and we've done like we've been homies
from like since like sixth grade we've
claimed each other to be cousins so we
Loki like look like each other's voices
grew up saying we're cousins and we've
always just treat each other like family
like that you know it means so yeah I
didn't see it as like a man I'm not I'm
kissing you because it's like affection
and I was just like just showing my true
like I'm here you know I'm right here
bro this is love that's dope because I
think I just never grew up see cuz I
think it's so weird because I could
picture myself having a son and giving
him kisses all the time yeah but I don't
know I can't see myself doing that to a
guy friend I could cry with the dude hug
the dude yeah something about kissing is
so [ __ ] intimate and just to see like
two rappers that talk about killin ya
and stuff and they just mouth each other
in front of the whole world it's like
damn that's some interesting [ __ ] yeah
especially because I feel like in the
hip-hop world there's a lot of like
anti-homosexuality oh yeah yeah they
call people what [ __ ] [ __ ] what
whatever no and that's a such a
prevalent insult but to see those type
of dudes kiss each other was like mmm
that's interesting yeah and and it was
even during the time that where there
wasn't any woke this was back in like
early 2000s to where that was straight
up like people were saying [ __ ] at the
time and they were saying oh that's gay
like yeah they're no homo wasn't even a
thing at the time oh that's right you're
saying no homo until like I don't know
like 2008 tomten you know a lot of
[ __ ] East Coast cats they're like on
that I think they have that no homo [ __ ]
but they say pause Alonzo is the big one
now so much it's like everything it's
yeah and like to me that's like I don't
even like that because when you say
pause you're you're putting into the
realm of the conversation that there's
something gay that was said yeah you
could have just said something without
saying pause and we could have still
kept talking yeah the conversation would
go yeah that subway the other day and I
had a whole foot long pause like know
you had a footlong and that's what it's
called it's called the [ __ ] yeah yes
sometimes be I'll let you want some
meatballs Paul
no they're freakin delicious it's
[ __ ] excessive sometimes I just won't
even make sense yeah pass me a pillow
pause I'm like what does that mean bro
yeah you actually want me to go like or
should I like play like do I actually
pause that's what I say I'll play when
people say Paula by knob I play yeah I
didn't I didn't get to really understand
what that [ __ ] was and then my friend
was like it's like the [ __ ] when you
guys say no homo
yeah asked what yeah yeah I get it it's
a little excessive but I don't like yeah
I don't like especially you're a grown
ass man you're an interview like camara
whoa who was it I saw um who's the guy
who was beefing with jay-z he's like a
big producer my mind just went blank
Oh somebody for jay-z besides knots no
no no yeah right but uh damn Dame - Oh
Dave - yeah yeah yeah bro I saw the
interview on Breakfast Club and he's
saying pause like so much and I'm like
first of all you hold yourself already
as like you had I'm a man I'm a man and
this is that is that's like that's kind
of you're already have you had that vibe
in the industry of like I don't [ __ ]
around
yeah are you saying pause that to me
doesn't really show like you're really
being a man like no say we should be
yeah yeah Paul's Paul's like no stop
saying Paul's I didn't see that [ __ ]
it yo I just heard about the whole like
Jay Z I don't Dame - his bro bro I heard
like yeah I have no idea of out of there
I still don't know what that was the Jay
Z beef I don't know a lot of the the
hip-hop beefs
I just know Tupac biggie I know Jake you
know I'm saying the Drake in me and that
was looking hilarity that was like fun
yeah that was like a fun beat I still
can't believe Meek Mill didn't come at
him hard because Meek Mill was a [ __ ]
battle rapper that's where he was fair
that was his [ __ ] yeah I wonder what
that [ __ ] was about that was so odd to
me I thought he was gonna [ __ ]
destroy this [ __ ] and then push
it he came out and then ripped that
Pusha T [ __ ] Colo push it when push
it put that stuff oh my god when he went
for forty and he was just like yeah he
was like he's sick sick sick I was like
you are a petty petty petty wrote but
the funny thing is I think when people
heard that you know because that that
type of like rap drama has been
happening for many [ __ ] years and I
feel like when people hate each other on
some [ __ ] like that
yeah you it's all [ __ ] it's all good
you could say whatever the [ __ ] you want
there but it was so weird when I kind of
read a lot of comments when they're like
yo he went too far I like what's too far
he doesn't like him he could say
whatever the [ __ ] you want because when
it comes to somebody you dislike why do
you have to why do you care about the
other person's wares or public
perception because it's just it's a it's
a [ __ ] battle yeah
where they're going at each other and
he's supposed to say something that's
supposed to hurt the guy no matter what
no yeah I strongly am behind the idea if
you're in the arts there's no boundaries
yeah if you're in the arts that's
entertainment that's that's
rapping that's music that's comedy
especially comedy yeah you have the
freedom of speech that's it here
especially when it comes to just [ __ ]
going at each other on diss tracks like
yo come on
that's why I [ __ ] your [ __ ] you fat
[ __ ] that's how the pop opened
up yeah that's pretty [ __ ] bad yeah
and that's just done at a [ __ ]
- although he wins that full spoke that
[ __ ] from his ball sack dude that [ __ ]
was from his spirit yeah so I was kind
of used to stuff like that so when
people kind of came out and they said
that it was a little too far I'm like
nah man like it's a [ __ ] it's a diss
track you're trying to diss somebody
they're supposed to go making a rhyme
it's actually very like impressive the
track rhyming at the same time on a beat
and push it's he's not a new wage rapper
- that [ __ ] a legend so it's
like what did you expect what's gonna
happen yeah and it was so weird when I
saw Noah's gonna be some hard [ __ ] yeah
I feel like I think that generation gap
is it's it's kind of more prevalent when
I see stuff like that I don't know if I
feel that people cuz sometimes people
say like the younger generation is a
little too sensitive but I don't know I
feel like everybody had their generation
thing where there was a group that was
too sensitive mm-hmm you know and I
think it's just like cyclical yeah
right yeah and and I think now because
there's social media it's like the cool
thing to be offended of something yeah
like to be like oh that's offensive yeah
so that because what I realized that
when people say oh that's offensive and
they go by making a post they're making
that post so that they can see that
everybody's are going along with them so
that they can feel like a leader of
something mmm like I just started this
movement yeah you know I mean like
they're looking for their hashtag me too
yeah you know I mean so so that's what I
feel like within this generation because
of social media
are you really offended or are you
seeing something that could be offensive
and then you go about highlighting and
going oh this is offensive am i right
guys oh yeah man who's following me I
for sure I think it's like the cool cool
kid thing to do yeah it's kind of like I
mean how I would express it I'm not sure
if this is the exact analogy but it's
when it's when that one white kid right
yeah says something that's very uh I
guess introspective in black culture
right and he'll be like yeah because you
know why people done it and they'll be
like a couple of black homies are like
man you know what
with us yeah I think that's the type of
gas that they get with it right uh-huh
when it comes to them speaking about
stuff that they may not really know
about but they know that they have like
this support behind that makes them feel
very inclusive right right yeah so I
think that's what people like a lot they
like that thing where it's like oh I
know what's up I'm woke yeah I'm woah
yeah I know what's up
which I do appreciate people kind of
bringing a lot of things to light like
we were just talking about it earlier
where I think on this podcast and when I
have conversations with a lot of my
female friends I [ __ ] you not I say
about a good 40% of them have been
sexually assaulted once in their life is
specifically when they were younger that
kind of threw me off a little bit
because when we were younger they didn't
talk about it and not like they like
they would because it's such a traumatic
thing that happens to them mm-hmm but
I've been finding out more and more
often that a lot of these girls and
because of this walk movement yeah they
are being more open about in the more
understanding is I never really
understood completely what rape culture
meant because when people talked about
rape culture how I processed it was
people are saying that men believe that
raping is okay which I don't believe I
think that you me a a hundred percent of
the guys that I'm around mm-hmm
understand that rape is a yeah [ __ ]
terrible yeah there is it somebody in my
group that says rapist well what's the
situation there's no the guy in the
group we're starting off going hey is
this rape so I was with this girl yeah
yeah for sure
because you also have like what bill
bill birthday and he said it so well he
was like there's like the you weren't
saying no no stop it was the yeah you
know and it's a it's a playful thing to
where like yeah I've had that to where
and the girl ends up like oh my god like
you're so bad and then we end up like
messing around but it's not it's like
it's consensual
yeah that's not a that's not a no get
off me stop what you like get away from
me that like yeah yeah that's I guess a
guy to if you don't know that damn
difference then you're a [ __ ] rapist
but yeah for sure cuz you know there's
rapport with that right yeah there's
like you when this girl probably have
known each other for a while
you're dating you're flirting things are
going great yeah and then she says the
no stop type of things yeah then that's
a different type of no stop you're a guy
that has to wonder like y'all did I [ __ ]
it and do something wrong it's like well
then you probably did yeah you
definitely yeah very sad in the bed in
the fetal position crying you probably
did something wrong exactly you know
this podcast is brought to you by
Skillshare yeah we're talking about
skill sharing we're talking about
lifelong learning we're talking about
hundreds and thousands of courses that
could help you pursue the stuff that you
want to pursue whether it's a lifelong
passion whether it's a hobby if it's
something that you're just curious about
Skillshare probably has those courses
for you for me personally I've been
using on the photography side I've been
doing photography for quite a while now
but there's always something that I need
to brush up on and with photography
videography goes in hand-in-hand
specifically when it comes to coloring I
know a lot of people when they do their
videos they don't even know where to
start or how to color how to look at our
B RGB scales how to look at histograms
all this other stuff and if you want to
learn like fundamental basics and you
didn't want to learn that in a
traditional sense where you have to go
to like photography school or
videography school or or some kind of
like proprietary program Skillshare is
gonna be the spot for you because I
personally like learning at my own pace
and I want to learn what I want to learn
at the comfort on my home it makes it
easier for me to learn the subjects that
I am interested in well check this out
my friends ah you can join the millions
of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for my listeners get two months of
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering genius brain
listeners two months of unlimited access
to thousands of classes for free to sign
up go to Skillshare comm slash brain
again go to Skillshare comm slash brain
to start your two months now that skill
share comm slash brain but that's what
I'm saying like I think like as a guy
you don't really realize what a lot of
these girls go through and it is an
adult and now that I'm getting older and
I think I'm a lot more empathetic than
when I was younger mm-hmm not I think I
am it's kind of crazy how many of these
girls I know that have been through a
traumatic thing like that yeah and they
just never spoke up about it yeah they
never [ __ ] did yeah I had a couple of
friends who told me it was
and you know what everybody that did get
sexually assaulted if I'm recollecting
correctly it was somebody that either
that they knew huh really close though
it was like a family [ __ ] friend or it
was a [ __ ] family member
yeah which is [ __ ] crazy and it's
crazy because they don't even know that
it was a traumatic thing until later on
until later on now that these things are
coming up and people are understanding
that this was a bad thing that this is
this is trauma then they're like oh wait
oh yeah I got touched yeah yeah it's
probably it it definitely affected me
like the way I was going I just thought
you know it feels a family member they
thought were just playing this is a new
game you know I mean like it's that's
that was something like that's happened
in my family it was like a game we were
playing you know they always think oh
it's fun yes I get kids y'all are paid
yank a dick got the [ __ ] crazy uncle
with his dick down what you gonna do you
gonna pull on my dick and the Candy's
gonna come out my mouth I said what's
that
was that you guys like whipped cream
right is I'm a dick yeah really game
where you lick whipped cream off
anywhere alright so start off with the
NexStar elbow and they did - yeah bro I
what's it called a [ __ ] manual from
Dorne obtainment he lightly touched on
it but he talked about the story where
good pun lightly touched yeah he lightly
ball touched on the story but there was
this dude in his neighborhood he was
like an older cat he was like the
neighborhood friend or an older older
friend or some [ __ ] like that and you
know the family knew him and everything
else like that he would come over and I
guess he said as a kid that's due to
whip out his [ __ ] dick and then
Emmanuel knew that something was a
little off anyone's mom you know and
whatever how child's how children call
how however a child will call it dick he
goes whatever mom like his peepee is out
of whatever but I ever saw that dude
again but he was hanging around little
kids trying to play a game or some [ __ ]
well and I don't know where that [ __ ]
perversion comes from yeah like okay
well how am I gonna get these kids to
somehow touch my dick yeah it's like a
little [ __ ] an eyebrow over his dick
hole and then like a closed eye yeah
yeah look into the winking eye yeah [ __ ]
do you think about it is a weird
concept I mean specifically for me I
think it's just weird for adults too if
I were to break it down into words
because I mean sexuality is such an
animal thing right like animals want to
reproduce and you usually want to do
that with someone that's that can
reproduce yeah just from a from a
scientific point of yeah yeah right yeah
but what do you see in a child right
that's the weird part
you know what I mean it's [ __ ] gross
yeah anyway yeah no they stink they're
funny I'm a [ __ ] like I don't understand
what the [ __ ] it is yeah and and and I
think I think a lot of it has to do with
vulnerability like they they know that
that because once they're think they're
so yet they're sick they're sick minded
that the adult right and they probably
can't get it from any of the people
their age whatever and it's like if a
kid is doesn't know they just have no
idea they're able the doll is able to
satisfy it whatever they whatever their
want is to a person a kid that is like
completely vulnerable I'm saying like
being a parent it's it's so like you
have to be cautious about [ __ ]
everything yeah and it's weird that it
happens the most with people that you
know what scares the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
me now I have a kid I'm just like who
the [ __ ] trying to [ __ ] my kid like
that's the thing I brought in my head
yeah you'll be really [ __ ] funny
though what if like you grow up and then
I'll you're hanging out with your
friends and everybody's talking about
this one doing the neighborhood that
sexually harassed everybody bugging you
and then you feel a certain way about it
yeah I was like how come on you get
touched yeah and then you have the
moments of like oh this is the fucked-up
part is with boys they're like yo you
know that Oh Miss Rose down the street
is like showing her tits she does she
just walks around with no - and then
you're thinking you're actually that's
actually still you know what is it uh
like Milla station or whatever like they
say Sanjay K news how weird it is that
obviously with if a guy showed his dick
to a young group of girls and he's
[ __ ] disgusting yeah right it is
that's to me I'm just like I'll [ __ ]
murder this dude right but if if it was
like let's let's put let's put
age limit on it right so let's say for
example your your 13 year old let's say
14 year old boy and you're in high
school your freshman right yeah and
there's just hot ass substitute teacher
and that substitute teacher showed you
her titties yeah I don't think the first
thing that would come to a guy's mind
even as he gets older and he recollects
that thought was that he got sexually
harassed that's what I'm gonna say right
right so like I think as a young man you
for some reason you think that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] right that's what I'm saying
like you still get sexually harassed but
it's like was it traumatizing was it bad
why isn't it looked at is bad why is you
know what I mean why is it for us that
woman that maybe it's because of the
eminent danger isn't there right because
you know physically men can overpower
younger women right yeah so maybe that's
like the the danger that's within it and
bees can't fit in a but he makes
t-shirts we're putting that on a teacher
can fit into but there's definitely
something along with that though I'm
yeah you're like that the penetration
aspect of it or even that it's just I
feel like even though it's a
fourteen-year-old boy he might be able
to overpower her physically mm-hmm so
that eminent danger isn't there because
the boy doesn't feel like he's in danger
if he doesn't participate in this right
because the only danger of a boy not
participating in that would probably if
he told that story and other kids made
fun of him right but I feel like for a
girl there's a physical danger to it as
well yeah my that's the that's the
biggest [ __ ] difference like if a
girl let's say the guy what that is
[ __ ] dick yeah and he tried to
physically assault her yeah and she's
physically weaker than him then what is
she going to do yeah you know yes the
stakes are higher the stakes are a lot
higher for a girl [ __ ] up something if
I have a daughter man I'm scared man I
hope I hope my daughter is the ugliest
thing ever and only daddy finds it
beautiful i praying dude like she comes
out she got like this [ __ ] weird like
weird tooth coming out of here one i
smell or the other yeah yeah my ugly
daddy thinks you're beautiful but let me
tell you nobody ever wanted to touch you
growing up so right here
[Laughter]
oh my god have you ever had a moment
growing up where you're like am i gay
you know I think that moment only
happened because people were [ __ ]
around I'm glad that you actually have
had one because I've had one for sure if
I want to hear yours I feel I don't know
if it's because I thought I was gay I
think it's because as a kid you're gay
and that word it didn't really have that
definitive meaning of like um because I
feel like when we use that where you're
gay it was just as an insult had nothing
to do with sexuality right yeah but I
think when people started joking around
with it a lot though you could probably
be gay yeah yeah okay can that happen
like can I be gay yeah does that work
that way right and I think I feel like a
lot of boys felt that [ __ ] Oh
first sure well I have this theory that
every guy has had a mi hey my game Oh
every guy for sure especially gays that
mean that's where they were like oh yeah
for sure gay moment will you chill at
your homey and just you guys are having
such a good [ __ ] time yeah over items
like amen
well can't my girl just be like you it's
like yes go pee right right yeah bro I'd
like I've had those I've had those
moments bro or it's like cuz cuz also
like in school I wasn't um I wasn't a
jock I wasn't super athletic I boxed you
know but I was really into dancing I was
into arts and crafts I was into
crocheting like my dad walked in walked
in on me crocheting and my dad was like
you might be gated yeah your dad came in
is like boy I thought you boxing if my
dad were like making me a [ __ ] beanie
why aren't you why I thought you'll be
walking in on you like jacking off yes
but you're crocheting you know start
jacking off immediately I'm a closest
damn door and I want to hear some
thumping but yeah bro and and so that
was my thing I was like I'm not I don't
feel as masculine so I was like damn am
i gay you know I've had those moments
for sure
I think that's more of a lot of kids or
guys feel like they might be homosexual
not because of their actual sexual
attraction towards another male is
because a lot of people put masculinity
on things that aren't really masculine
or feminine right yeah
for example crocheting like making [ __ ]
why is that considered quote unquote
gift yeah right is making [ __ ] even for
me I didn't join quiet for the longest
time because I was scared bro yes
elementary school choir was only for
girls yeah that was it and my brother
was like it my brother was like dude
don't don't quad cuz I wanted to do
choir cause I want to learn how to sing
yeah I never did because I thought it
was something girls did girls that's
what I'm saying so there's just a lot of
and you know things are changing a lot
now yeah but for sure there was just a
lot of things that were put as only guys
do this only girls through this yeah for
example this is a great example I didn't
use a lotion because I thought that [ __ ]
was for [ __ ] I was like you use
lotion you [ __ ] [ __ ] but you can't
throw a fist where the [ __ ] does dry
skin got a ding a man or and right yeah
so a lot of dudes they don't do skincare
[ __ ] they don't use lotion on their face
and all the other stuff and I didn't use
it for the longest time until Mariel my
fiance told me my fin my skin was trash
I said what you talk about muskets fine
jeez I know it's dry as hell Tom and
then as I'm speaking like flakes are
coming off my face but I didn't know
this type of stuff about skin care and
my skin was terrible because something
in the back of my mind told me that skin
cares for a bunch of pansies and wusses
yeah so you don't do that type of [ __ ]
bro you're just moisturize in your
[ __ ] skin right doesn't make any
sense but all that stuff as a kid
affects you as an adult right so all
that you know pro man [ __ ] that I
thought that only guy should do or only
girl should do those type of activities
is never touched right and eventually
like what the whole choir thing I was
like yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] join choir
and I'm gonna sing and I'm gonna do it
publicly and I'm gonna see what's gonna
happen like right who the [ __ ] cares
yeah
and which doesn't make any sense because
my favorite singers were we're [ __ ]
male singers yeah that's what I will say
I was like you got Michael Jackson uh
sure Chris Brown Justin Bieber and they
all got mad [ __ ] he's unlike
what you mean this is gala I could have
been that yeah that was my first concert
I ever went to was ushered 8701 is my
first color and I knew at that moment I
want to be an entertainer that's where
that's where I found out I want to be
entertainer because there's one guy on
the stage we're in a whole stadium yeah
and people just roaring roaring for this
one guy and I was like that's just so
badass he was dancing it was so [ __ ]
cool so I was like yeah that's what I
want to do but singing I was like I
can't think so maybe I'll just be a man
who knows if they didn't crush your
dreams you could have been the next
Usher
oh yeah well you danced don't tell me
that yes yeah that's why I can't sing
these [ __ ] go No yeah I was I was
dancing all through high school but not
seen but that's what I was but I was
performing in talent shows dancing I was
that's what I was known for before even
comedy I was known for dancing
yeah yeah yeah and so but that was like
that was my thing I was like alright I'm
a I'm gonna take singing lessons later
like in life but I'm gonna get them
dancing down right I got into acting so
I was like okay I got the acting down I
wanted to be a triple threat so bad this
podcast is brought to you by purple baby
I love my purple mattress I've been
sleeping on it so well and ever since
I've had it I've had the best nights of
sleeps my whole life this mattress is
firm and soft at the same time it keeps
me nice and cool and on top of that my
friends it was developed with some
rocket science behind it the purple
mattress is by far the best mattress
I've ever ever slept on and I'm not just
saying that I have insomnia and I have
back problems and this mattress has
helped both of those ailments out a lot
for me personally so if you're sleeping
on a rock and you're sleeping on a super
super hard bed then my friends you need
to get yourself a purple mattress now
you're going to love purple and right
now my listeners will get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to the great free
gifts they're offering site-wide just
takes brain into eight four - eight
eight eight the only way to get this
free pillow is a text brain - eight four
eight eight eight that's be are a I n28
for a
8:8 message and data rates may apply you
know I wanted to just be like a gym like
a box yeah yeah yeah jamie foxx dancing
was the [ __ ] though i think honestly out
of all the talents in terms of getting
women to be attracted to you
the dancers always had the best they
would always get the most when the only
thing with me with dancers but this is
what kind of threw me off because I was
like everybody was like oh damn that's
gonna be cool like you'll be like Chris
Brown's backup dancers you'll be Usher's
backup dancers and I saw that as like
I'm gonna be a background dancer yeah I
feel like I was like nobody pays
attention to the background now I know
now like there's a lot of famous dancers
that you want to see that are with
Beyonce like the last one is like there
you're watching the them because you're
fans of them and of course they're on
with Beyonce but I was always like
you're just watching the main
entertainer you're not watching your
dancers yes so that also kind of
discouraged me away from wanting to be a
dancer because I was like you're not
gonna be the main show yeah now I mean
of course that's you know me being
ignorant cuz I know there's a ton of
successful dancers that are but you know
dancing wasn't as lucrative as it is now
mm-hmm so the dancing was such a big
passion it was a huge performance art
mind you even a lot of these great
backup dancers just from what I've heard
until they until that fuse there's a few
small select amount of people that get
paid a lot to choreograph and dance and
everything else but everybody else
relatively they don't for the amount of
work that they do they don't get paid
that well on my shirt like they twins
right like more then because they have a
name they can negotiate their prices
right right you have a walk use like
exactly yeah so prior to the whole
social media thing and people really
putting like dancing on the map like
that it wasn't a huge little it wasn't a
lucrative business but would open up
their own studios and stuff right but
that was based on a small group of
people who wanted to learn how to dance
right because prior to the whole you
know what's it called not America like a
ABDC Imagineers Dance Crew right right
how many I mean I knew about a few
boutique hip-hop studios right or you
would join like a small dance troupe and
then you will learn how to dance there
right but there wouldn't be these
hardcore intense
hip-hop classes where you learn how to
dance on these great choreographers
alright it wasn't really no but now you
have stuff like movement lifestyle what
everybody wants to go there right I mean
they get some of the best [ __ ]
hip-hop choreographers around around the
world yes train people in the asses
which is amazing yeah bro cuz because
you probably had to learn how did you
learn how to dance on your own
yeah that's how most people did it you
got served yeah they had special
features or where they did little at the
end uh with the other DVD you can they
had like uh you can learn a couple like
choreographies yeah that they had the
the main choreographer that that taught
that's still around on them dance yeah I
watched that like over and over and then
we don't two came out I was watching all
the Omarion videos Chris Brown videos
and just well that [ __ ] movie made
everybody wanna dance yeah even me I
knew I couldn't dance my [ __ ]
you best believe I'd be somebody that
taught somebody to do a backflip I'm not
the [ __ ] you gonna jump at me alright
I don't dance right now Matassa [ __ ]
act like a coin and I'ma get the glory
because I threw you yeah bro that was
the same boat trying to serve people yep
sir sir yes sir doing it for a little
saint was [ __ ] dope don't think it's
one of those it's probably one of the
best dance movies out there man in terms
of like hip hop
acting's trash oh who the [ __ ] cares
about that though I had no idea that the
acting was tries until like I watched it
now I had no idea that it was like what
is this
have you seen Karate Kid yeah oh look at
the like have I seen that like recently
recently the original one no the worst
acting you'll ever see in your life
there's some funny-ass scenes in that
film because you know it was at Pat
Morimoto the you know Alexa and Alexa
mr. Miyagi mr. Miyagi right so mr.
Miyagi I don't know his real name
yeah I think it's Pat Morimoto or
something but I think I hate that I
don't know it but a man mr. Miyagi
Misaki mr. Miyagi there's a scene where
he's fighting like in this Japanese
garden type of area but they clearly had
these stunt doubles that are switching
out from him right but it's too apparent
it's like the scene switches and the
dudes like 4 inches tall he looks way
younger really which is out that it's
Pat Morimoto again yeah
the movies pretty bad and oh it's bad
dude you should watch it it's it's
pretty know about one two up dad's gonna
hurt me yeah always thought that it was
mr. Miyagi just straight up nah it's a
stunt double Wow so as a kid we think
it's so amazing and as an adult when I
watched it I was like yo this this
movie's pretty bad the acting is pretty
bad too the guy who played a Daniel
Larusso so [ __ ] stiff mm-hmm would
have never thought and it's such a weird
concept because that film is about an
Italian kid that does karate better than
everybody else
everybody in that crowd competition is
[ __ ] white yeah why don't I don't
know why I put any of these things like
together it's like this [ __ ] don't make
sense yeah like coming that's like
Scarface being played by Al Pacino
that's uh what is Alpert's you know he's
uh he's Italian mm that's right yeah
Scarface was [ __ ] mom though yeah but
it was that that was that was like
there's no famous Latin actor to play
yeah yeah you know so now you have a
scarf Al Pacino what's he know he did
pretty good but you know I thought it
was weird when Will Smith did that one
film where he was supposed to play the
that football coach that was supposed to
be an African football coach oh yeah
yeah no he was the concussion you took
my question he was a doctor
he's a dot yeah yeah I just I didn't see
the film but I saw the trailer I was
like better the worst action I've ever
heard of my life I would be truth yeah
Will Smith I know you do but to death I
want the truth
yes I can help you see that no no I
couldn't watch it man yeah I love will
though man so I hate he does social
media better than we do bro bro this
dude came on social media and just like
now now it's how can you be second best
because he's at the top well he got
money too he has money he has a
production he has a team but the thing
is is that he is so he's so like he
figured it out and that's why he'd been
out for so long because I'm pretty sure
he'd probably studied it yeah it's just
you could tell like he knows exactly the
timing of how social media works how
content works on social media like he's
not putting up little mini short movies
he's actually making some legit
get content you don't mean that he's
such a charismatic guy
yeah and he's tagging all these people
getting them numbers like he understands
the way it works is like making sure
that they get exposure like these these
um you know up-and-coming editors and
and these effect graphic designers as
though it that he's like yeah I'll put
you on like just make my [ __ ] look dope
find his tags a myth man he's he
definitely does [ __ ]
on some next-level stuff yeah how does
he come on this space that you know
we're supposed to be really good at yeah
he just destroys everyone yeah that
guy's so [ __ ] unique and still looks
the same like because you know you see
the times where he doesn't have the the
you know the the black [ __ ] in his hair
and his goatee where he's all like it's
all like peppery you have me but you
know he puts that on he looks just like
men in black yeah you know I mean like
it's crazy how how young he still looked
at you forget they he's he's 51 he's 51
now yeah
he's 50 his things like that that whole
jumping up there the the helicopter was
last year that was his about 50 50 years
50s yeah celebration jumping out of a
helicopter and that's crazy and he's
still doing dope [ __ ] bro I [ __ ] love
that guy like I think Fresh Prince was
one of those shows that really molded a
lot of people's yeah one comedy yeah and
just their whole childhood and how they
selves yeah yeah it was such a cool show
to [ __ ] watch yeah for sure
I wasn't he wasn't even supposed to be
casted for that show I heard originally
really I forgot who else it was supposed
to be but if somebody really famous that
we should know of
mmm but they passed it up and then Will
Smith auditioned for the role and then
he got it and it changed his whole
[ __ ] career and at the time I heard
he was going bankrupt cuz he just he
just blew all and yeah the tax thing
yeah he blew all his money think about
taxes and he was looking going bankrupt
or some [ __ ] yeah it was you know he
never paid any of his taxes that's what
it was that's just [ __ ] crazy any of
his taxes and then the IRS basically
like seized all his stuff and like just
went to zero everything that's [ __ ]
crazy yeah it's crazy bro that's yeah a
lot of bloody celebrities have some
weird stories man growing up and I feel
for him to like I wonder what history
jetters like cuz I heard that he well I
think he said that he works every day as
if he doesn't have a single [ __ ] cent
in his name
which is how he keeps motivated
constantly yeah which I can understand
that too
because no matter how no matter what
position I am in life I think I'm always
gonna work hard because you know when
you don't come from anything I think
that's always like in the back of your
mind isn't [ __ ] I remember a time where
if when I went out to eat I wouldn't
even look at the food I'm like I look at
the number I'm like it was enough so I
could afford water I said lemon oh yes I
was that guy - when you look when I was
opening up menus I was looking on the
right side of my thing I wasn't looking
at letters I was looking at numbers
exactly it was like okay if it has an
extra number on it yeah we're gonna pass
that yeah and I hate it when they didn't
have the dotted line to guide you all
the way to that number because I'm like
is this macaroni $53 all this I say okay
Jesus I'm like trying to match them like
yeah do this [ __ ] when I was in high
school you know Taco Tuesdays Asian but
they had it for a Del Taco it was like
three tacos for a dollar and I remember
that was my favorite day of the week
I eat [ __ ] good today yeah I'm
against six tacos [ __ ] yeah yeah
hyped as hell right but now is it it's a
very weird thing where I you know I
talked about it on a previous podcast
where it was just kind of looking back
at all the things that you have now and
being grateful for the things that you
do have right because it's very easy to
kind of get caught up in your own
[ __ ] yeah because you forget where
you were before and you look at your
current state and then you say oh I
think that I deserve more right which is
okay and I think you could use that as
motivation but losing that perspective
is where people get [ __ ] up a lot yeah
you're looking on especially if you're
if you're on social media you're looking
at so many things that you could you
could also be doing like you see
everybody else's lives you're like oh
like I like even even up first is from
with women I didn't know that they were
so like when I was when I was in high
school it was just Wilbur was hot in
high school you know and then it was
like the hot celebrities like Jennifer
Lopez or Halle Berry but then that was
it now I'm on social media and I could
see a fine [ __ ] every scroll that you
know there's an Instagram model or the
then that's and that right there is a
title already in histogram model not
just a regular model not an actual paid
model that's you know on magazines and
doing print and doing all
know this you're an Instagram model and
that's actually like credited because
they you get could you get content deals
like I'm not I'm not giving them I give
them all the credit I get it yeah yeah I
mean there are some that are like what
is it thirst traps like that whatever I
wore here
there are IG models that really make
money out here I just say try to hear
some of them naming names but you know
there was a certain Instagram model that
I knew and for her I kind of lost a lot
of respect for her and sometimes people
get it twisted when they say oh that
person is really sweet it doesn't mean
that that I respect you just because
you're a nice person
I'm gonna [ __ ] I could not respect a
nice person all day what the [ __ ] is I
got to do with anything
uh-huh but you know I get tired of
people who just I don't like it when
people say I work I'm working hard all
the time I'm a hustling I'm grinding
there's like I know you like I know what
your version of working hard at getting
in and it's not you're not doing
anything at all you have a [ __ ] ton of
time during the day yeah it's annoying
to you right now and it seems like hard
work because he's been very repetitious
you're doing the same thing over and
over but a grand scheme of things of
what you do yeah you're not really doing
much I'm not saying this is for all
Instagram models because I know a lot of
them are trying to act they're hustling
they're getting the [ __ ] going on right
yeah it's hard to maintain an aesthetic
on Instagram consistently and be you
know work on that there's some fineness
like a waiter's that work at Chili's and
gonna find out that their Instagram
model but they gate they got to get
their hustle and they gotta get get
their bills pay so they've got to work
at Chili's exactly so when I you know
this girl to like I know she got she
would get like 30 grand deals just for
showing her ass and she's just like huh
man it was such a hard day I'm like
[ __ ] you hired a photographer he took a
few snaps you know two hours at your day
and then you say you're exhausted yeah
I'm I don't think you remember where you
were before in life you were just a
pretty girl around the block right but
somehow you you got lucky enough where
somebody found you way more attractive
than the other girl with the fat ass and
now this is what you're banking on yeah
and if you don't have that state of
gratitude you're not gonna really be
able to really see where you're at in
life right my thing is if you're showing
your butt and you're making money that's
[ __ ] dope yeah you should be able to
be aware enough to be like oh this is
actually easy money I'm doing a
I'm doing yeah compared to what you
could be doing yeah no like yeah work is
work I get that a hundred percent yeah
that's why I try not to complain about
my [ __ ] you know people I say oh you got
you got these [ __ ] food concepts
you're doing this and you know doing Sam
foods you're doing the podcast you doing
that and they're like man you must be
exhausted
mm-hmm I'm I like what I'm doing yeah so
am i exhausted I do get tired and
exhausted but I'm not gonna complain
about that exhaustion right because yeah
you know and I have before but I had to
snap myself out of it's like dog what
could you be doing right now where if
you weren't doing this what could you be
doing like I would probably be me
miserable yeah or I I don't know I'd be
doing stand-up or something but it's
that perspective that really kind of
helps me just lock where I am in place
yeah well sometimes we like I said if I
know what you're doing on an everyday
basis and then you're complaining to me
about how tired you are when you got
like 30 grand just to put up one photo
right yeah man is [ __ ] good dude yeah
I have I have I've actually just came to
this realization with myself because
like my girl she she works she works at
uh she's she's a vet tick so she works a
little pet hospital right and so you say
who I said that's dope oh okay
I was like yeah you know she she's very
hands-on with her work you know she's
always standing up you know they're not
really sitting down they're always
standing working picking up big animals
so she's really like hands-on and
physical work and my work is you know
I'm working from home I'm editing or I'm
doing a graphic design or I'm screen
printing or making content like a
voiceover so like that but it's hard to
translate that into like oh you're
really doing hard work yeah I mean
because you have somebody who is you
know working with animals dealing with
big dogs or feisty dogs and all those
things were like you really are
physically tired but you could also be
mentally tired when you're standing in
front of you know editing all night and
you're just like or all day like even
yesterday - I had to work on this brand
deal and I had to write a script out
yeah she [ __ ] took all day yeah you
know because I did go through the lines
going back and forth and
that's why it sometimes when mmm some
people say oh I wish I could do what
you're doing well your life must be
great yeah and I think that's kind of a
[ __ ] perspective to biz because just
because I'm good at what I do it doesn't
mean that I could do what you do right
it doesn't yeah right it's such a weird
thing for people to say I don't think
that you should be envious of other
people's career you shouldn't if there's
anything to be envious about it's kind
of what somebody else gets from the
career that they are in right so you
should be envious of somebody who's in a
career that enjoys what they're doing
because that's really the goal right
right cuz yeah I guess it would be great
if I was a doctor I mean in terms of
what it means socially like status wise
and the money but then doesn't mean I
can do it it's not something that's in
my lane right so I'm more envious of
people who are happy doing what they're
doing doesn't have anything to do
anything to do with fame or money
there's everything to do with the state
that they're in when they're doing their
job right that's what I'm envious of
right cuz when I see people even like
when I go to Hawaii that's why I love
[ __ ] Hawaii man there's people who
just work regular jobs and if you asked
them you know would you leave this
island to go maybe to the mainland and
then work on something bigger they go
why like I like it out here man see my
family my friends yeah you know I work
these jobs Brian I love being around
these people yeah I live in my place and
I'm good I'm happy yeah it's just such a
weird perspective I think specifically
we live in entertainment and we live in
LA so that becomes the center point to
what success is for everybody
recognition if you're not being
recognized then oh what are you doing
that's why when we're on send foods we
do this reoccurring joke that oh Tim's
famous - it's a [ __ ] joke right when
people feel bad they're like oh you
should be recognized - it's like it's a
[ __ ] joke yeah why do you care so
much whether I get I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah let me tell you something right now
if I found a bag outside my door with
two million dollars [ __ ] this
podcast is shutting down no I still do
what I'm doing now yeah you know I still
do what I'm doing now because I enjoy it
whether people want to recognize me for
it or not it's great to be a part of
something yeah I enjoy mm-hmm and it's
it's like recognition is not a
motivating factor for me yeah I as long
as I'm creating something that I'm proud
of
every day it's great like even the film
[ __ ] nobody really recognizes me for
that film per se but it fulfilled the
checklist that I wanted to do right I
wanted to create a film I wanted to go
into Sundance that people are like oh
you must have made a lot of money off
that [ __ ]
I made 0y snow dolls not that [ __ ] cuz
just it was a black-and-white film it
was an art film it was a very art house
film it wasn't gonna make a lot of money
yeah it makes you off that mm-hmm right
yeah so you know it's just the
perspective is a huge thing for people
and I think that's where people should
would really focus on it's like if
you're looking to if you look at
somebody else and you wish that you had
their career I think that's already
[ __ ] up oh yeah for sure
and III also I take I take a lot of
things for granted because I find myself
like my work ethic definitely needs work
because a lot from the perspective when
you're talking about a lot of people
will see me and play oh man you got
crazy really doing your thing you're
moving your numbers are going up on IG
and like you're you know I could tell
they sure your grind and it's showing
you're right but really if I'm being
completely honest with myself
I'm just getting by yeah because I've
literally from you know elementary
school to making the volcano projects in
science class I always knew that my
project was gonna be the [ __ ] mmm no
matter when like if it was due by Friday
I was doing it Thursday night but I knew
I was still gonna [ __ ] on everybody's
thing because I just knew that I was the
[ __ ] I just had that yeah that mentality
and it was like I still like my volcano
had little mini trees around it and I
painted put shadows and actual like
different color Gray's on it and like I
really like went in on it they're like
I'm just another mystery school so but I
always I always sat on that of like I'm
good enough to where like I'm gonna be
good and I've done that with my comedy
like I just well I just had a writing
session last night with one of my homies
and he told me that he was like he was
like bro you're funny but you're just
you're just funny enough yeah you know I
mean like you get by you can have a
great set and you say when when will but
I could I see that your set is it's not
punched the way that it could be punched
like could like
all these tags and jokes and within it
usually getting these laughs and then
tour people you get offstage people are
still coming you saying man I really
enjoyed your set but it could really be
like oh my god you had me crying and you
my stomach is like I have cramps like I
you know like I was really like cracking
up you know so that's my thing that I'm
trying to work on is like I got to
actually like instead of just relying on
my talent actually put some [ __ ] work
in yeah I mean there's a lot of people
like that even I listen to the Joe Rogan
podcast and there's a female comic named
Nikki Glaser oh yeah yeah and she was
talking about how she doesn't really
kind of put her all into her stand-up
mmm right meaning that because she she
goes I if it ain't broke don't fix it
because what I'm doing is great I'm
still killing it right but then I think
like Joe was telling us I yelled but
could you imagine how great you would be
if you took the time to develop that
[ __ ] yeah and it's true though
but like you know like I'm saying it
depends on what you want to get out of
this thing right anything that if you
want to be the like a top-tier stand-up
comic and you definitely got to put that
work in because I don't know too many
top-tier comics that that don't do that
right cuz even like Mickey glacier like
Glaser I think I'm mispronouncing Mickey
glacier okay Mickey glacier right she's
she's probably one of those top female
comic comics right but you know she
might she might even be the biggest
female comic out there if she I mean she
wouldn't know yeah unless she really
tried that way all right I'm giving her
[ __ ] advice but that's what Joe Rogan
was saying yeah so I and I agree with
that too because I think after a while
too when you start doing stuff
half-assed and you just kind of get
stale and then you'll be a point later
on ten years from now you're just like
oh [ __ ] I wish I would put more work in
yeah and that's the part that scares me
right right that's why I had to I had to
just come to terms with and just cuz I
started seeing people who you know in my
opinion aren't that funny but they're in
my class and they're like they're like
passing me up as far as like credits go
or like the stages that they're hitting
and I'm like well they put the work in
yeah I mean and and I'm always just like
imma [ __ ] kill it like by the time I
went but when my opportunity comes
because there's also that too which also
it's kind of [ __ ] up because people
say you know don't rush into things or
when it when it's your time is your time
but that don't mean be lazy that I mean
like sit and wait for that time to
happen yeah I mean it's supposed to just
continue state will stay working stay
committed and when that time come when
that time comes you'll be ready because
you've been putting in the work Oh 100%
under me yeah so that's just that's just
my deal that I've I've didn't have him
to work on I've talked to uh you know my
cousin about my people about like y'all
I gotta get on my [ __ ] because I've been
sitting on my talent for too long that's
why like that's what I like about
kev-kev always working hard man it's
like one of those guys yeah one of those
guys that what I thought too am i man
[ __ ] yeah you can see how hard he works
and how much he enjoys what he's doing
and how grateful he is yeah and I think
that is the biggest part in my life that
I was missing for the past few years but
just like talking to him a couple of
times I'm like damn man it's kind of
really enjoys what he's doing yeah and
and because of that he works so hard I
mean when he gets on stage to be clear
yeah keV keV on stage everybody [ __ ]
kill on stages and it was so weird it
was like confuse with Kevin Hart so wow
yeah well Kevin Hart prayers to his back
because I broke his [ __ ] I heard like
he's he hasn't even been on social media
for a minute man yeah must be really
[ __ ] hurt yeah man and I really I
really do hope everything was cool the
the story is a little weird but I hope
everything's his friend was driving the
car and she was driving but him like him
him going to the house immediately like
he got they got sent to the house like
20 minutes before the cops came and all
these things like yeah they took him out
and took him home so I was like why did
you that hmm why it like especially
because he you could have gotten
paralyzed if you moved the wrong way
whatever yeah you're trying to move out
you're done for the neck down so it was
just that was just like that's why I was
like man I hope I hope of course
everything is gonna be okay whatever but
you know those are those type of
situations it's like what's going on I
feel like for him he's just so on top of
the world he got to do crazy [ __ ] to
feel something you know what I mean
yes that's why celebrity I heard that's
why celeb redo die even though the
heterosexual they just start [ __ ]
anything oh yeah I've heard those
stories yeah
always your that stories don't go to
this certain like when you go to this
certain person's house or party whatever
don't stay too late like oh that yeah
yeah they go they get so much [ __ ] that
they just gotta try anything at that
where they try first of all they go from
[ __ ] the butthole that is like I wonder
what that guy's [ __ ] yeah and this
you just kind of get this weird I've
heard that story so many times with
people I don't know what the [ __ ] they
has to be true yeah as I keep hearing it
over and over right I don't I don't want
to spread rumors about celebrities but
there's a big-name celebrities right
over here I've heard I've heard those
stories too and I'm listening it from
multiple people so it's just yeah like
this is weird
yeah and it's like different different
situations but same person and his
personal story so I'm like what the [ __ ]
it has to be really yeah at this point
and I feel like that that at that moment
that they probably had those thoughts
when they were younger of like am i gay
rich no they're like oh my god yeah God
God would do whatever he wants
yeah oh damn alright so well that wraps
this episode geez brave podcast where we
talk about but [ __ ] and touching yeah
I don't even think I completed my
thought about the the female females in
my life that got like touched when they
were younger but that's just [ __ ] up
but I don't know you had a pretty solid
a section and okay thank God I wanted to
say about that was that basically like I
understand now that I've heard these
stories multiple times what women mean
by about rape cultures not that men
think that it's okay it's just it's just
one of those things where it's if they
don't think it's okay why has it
happened to so many women at a certain
age and if it's like not every guy out
there and for me I know a lot of people
and I say about 40 percent of these
girls have been touch when they were
younger yeah it says something about our
society that's a little [ __ ] oh yeah
you know oh yeah and there you have and
then you have the other very [ __ ] up
part where all the girl has to say is I
got touched
yeah and that guy's career is done man I
could get I could get into a whole story
about you know I'll just tell the story
okay but I knew somebody in high school
she wasn't somebody that I [ __ ] knew
per se not my not my
Renne friend but she tried calling the
cops on a buddy of mine let's not even
call him a buddy of mine he's kind of
hot trash - okay this is my past but
basically she said that she was raped by
him right yeah what's not yeah what's
not and it was because they broke up and
it was a situation where they broke up
and she didn't like that you know like
you're jealous about the girl that that
the new the new girl that he's with yeah
and there was this whole [ __ ] ordeals
like oh he raped me blah blah blah long
story short I Pro made up this whole
[ __ ] lie
that dude was a thug he [ __ ] killed
his dude like straight up like
executioner style with a bunch of his
thug ass home e's he went to jail and so
did the other girl who told him about
the whole raping situation that killed
the guy that was accused of rape yeah he
did anything he didn't even touch touch
her right and the reason why I say he's
not my friend like that it's kind of
weird to call the do my friend but we
did hung around in the same circle I
gotcha
but yeah that dude and I'd be a lot more
sad if he was like a really close friend
of mine but you know sad enough he got
all scared of guns tear I'm a [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah he got he got killed and she
went to jail along with everybody else
that was a part of it because of a lie
yeah right cuz she said she got raped
yeah I'm pretty sure a lot of pressure
most girls don't do that [ __ ] but you
know there is that's [ __ ] one [ __ ]
maniac that rules it for the rest
because of some [ __ ] like that we've
done a bunch of articles on JK knees
where that has happened where they they
they ruin it for other women who were
actually going through this [ __ ] yeah
because they're [ __ ] insane yeah
they're saying they're jealous envious
or they want money that's why that's why
that Cosby [ __ ] when nobody would
believe that Cosby would do that stuff
you're right be gross like haha this
girl's making up the [ __ ] story but
once you know witness 672 came out sorry
oh maybe maybe this there might be
something to this because I was one of
those too because when the whole Bill
Cosby situation come out because Bill
Cosby was one of my biggest influences
mhm
maybe not so much a stand-up but the
show The Cosby Show okay
one that came outside cosby didn't touch
anybody yeah
then I started hearing stories about
everything he's done personal stories
from people and I'm like ah this this is
definitely true yeah nobody not
everybody's story could be fabricated
that much with that many people yeah
it's kind of hard to say yeah yeah the
proof is in the blue
I don't want he went to jail though some
of the inmates didn't [ __ ] jail the
pudding at him
did they really yeah [ __ ] hilarious
he's blind now I'm so sorry
but anyways guys that rest this episode
of the Jesus brave podcast you could
catch us on Spotify stitcher all those
audio podcast iTunes and all that make
sure you give us a five star and we'll
catch y'all next time
Oh Christine Oh or Chris I like to call
Christine oh no that's cool bro there's
not a lot of people communist so you got
it Hank plugging your [ __ ] alright so
you can found me on Instagram or all
platforms Instagram Facebook Twitter at
Christine o Sosa CRI STI and Oh salsa
like Sammy pluggin podcaster and my
podcast is keeping it real ya feel me
and that's on iTunes and Spotify and
we're gonna get it back on YouTube like
again we're figuring out the the footage
things and stuff like that so but yeah
keeping it true I'll see y'all next time
SAS peace